here's the truth though because if a man
came to you and you truly loved him and
he set you down got everything out the
way and you were needing me and he
looked you dead in the eyes and said
listen I really care about you obviously
I'm gonna see other women there's no way
I'll ever have feelings for them I want
to take care of you completely I want to
be the man that makes your dreams come
true let's go to the dark side of the
moon no I'm gonna be the rock that your
emotional ways crash into I am there for
you I am in love with you let's have
kids I might have sex with women every
now and then she that girl's delusional
she doesn't know
and and he tells you the truth instead
of being a coward see the problem is you
don't like a man that's going to be a
coward and lie behind your back because
he's too much of a to tell you the
truth you know the truth you know the
truth from the jump that every man wants
to do it it's the respect of sitting you
down and telling you the truth
furthermore most often when a woman
truly truly loves a man she does not
want to sleep with other men at all it's
not this oh you get to do it I want to
do it too because she's so in love with
the man she just wants to be with the
man